in a video game val scored 30 percent
fewer points than peta
peta scored
1060 points how many points did val
score pause this video and see if you
can figure out how many points val
scored
all right well now let's do this
together and there's a couple of ways
that you could think about it one way to
think about it is peta scored
1060 points and val scored 30 percent
fewer when we're saying 30 fewer we
we're saying essentially take 30 percent
of 1060 and subtract that from 1060. so
30 so that we could write that as a
decimal is 0.30
30 hundredths is the same thing as
thirty percent or we could even write
this as point three and then we would
want thirty percent of ten sixty
so if you take p to score and then
subtract thirty percent of p to score
then this would give you val score so
that's one way to calculate it another
way to think about it is
whatever you're starting with let's call
that 100
and if you were to take out 30 percent
of it if you were to have 30 percent
less then you're going to have 70
percent of what you started with so
another way to think about it is we
could take peta score
of 1060 and multiply it by 70 percent
and multiplying it by 70 is the same
thing as multiplying it by 0.70
which is the same thing as multiplying
it by 70 hundredths is the same thing as
7 10. so let's just do this so if i have
1060
and i multiply by
0.7
what do i get 7 times 0 is 0 7 times 6
is 42
7 times 0 0 plus 4 is 4 7 times 1 is 7
and i have one digit to the right of the
decimal so there you have it it is 742
742 that is how many points val scored
let's do
another example
so we're told there are 20 percent more
goblins than wizards in a magic club
there are 220 goblins and wizards all
together in magic club
how many goblins are in the magic club
so pause the video and see if you can
work through this on your own
so this one is an interesting one it's
going to involve a little bit of algebra
here so what we want to do is let's set
a variable let's say w is the number of
wizards
so that's the number of wizards and then
if we said g for goblins let's say g for
goblins so w plus g
is equal to 220
is equal to 220 and you're like well how
does that help me how does that help me
actually figure out how many goblins are
in the magic club i have two variables
here with one equation
well one way to think about it is
remember they give us more information
they tell us there are 20 let me
box that there are 20 percent more
goblins than wizards so we also know one
other thing we know that the goblins we
know that the goblins are equal to the
number of wizards plus 20 percent
so you could view this as
wizards
plus 20
of wizards and i'm writing that as 20
hundredths or you could even write that
as two-tenths plus two-tenths times the
number of wizards or another way of
thinking about it goblins are equal to
if i have one of something and then i
have another two-tenths of that
something then i'm going to have 1.2 of
that something so goblins is equal to
1.2 times the wizards and so we could
use that
to substitute back in here
and then we could say the number of
wizards
plus the number of goblins which happens
to be 20 percent more than the number of
wizards is going to be equal to
200
220. let me do that in the same color is
equal to 220. now this is pretty
straightforward to solve what is w plus
1.2 w well that is going to be 2.2 w 2.2
w you could use this as 1 w plus 2 plus
1.2 w is 2.2 w is equal to
220
and so just divide both sides let me
scroll down a little bit divide both
sides by 2.2
2.2
and what do you get
you get
w the number of wizards is equal to
let's see this is going to be equal to
100. the number of wizards is equal to
100. now is that our answer
no they're asking how many goblins are
in the magic club
well we know that goblins are 1.2 times
the wizards so
the number of goblins is going to be 1.2
times 100 which is equal to 120. so
there's 120 goblins and that makes sense
120 is 20 more than 100 and if you add
the 100 wizards to the 120 goblins you
get 220 goblins and wizards all together
let's do another example
here we're told cody was 165 centimeters
tall on the first day of school this
year which was 10 percent taller than he
was on the first day of school last year
how tall was cody on the first day of
school last year
pause this video see if you can figure
that out
so let's just define a variable here
let's just say that
the his height on the first day of
school last year let's say that that is
x
so his height on the first day of school
last year is x this year he is 10
taller so we would add 10 percent which
you could say is 10 hundredths or we
could even say that as one-tenth he's
one-tenth taller
so whatever his height was last year
we're going to add a tenth of that same
height again to get to his height this
year which they tell us is 165
centimeters
and so here we could say well one x plus
a tenth of an x is going to be one and
one tenth x is equal to 165
and now to solve for x which remember
was his height on the first day of
school last year we divide both sides by
1.1
and so x is equal to well let's see what
this is going to be
if i were to take 165
divided by
1.1 the first thing i would want to do
is move this multiply them both by 10.
so that has the effect of moving this
decimal place one to the right so really
i am now trying to figure out what 11
goes into 1
650 is and so let's see let me just do
that step by step 11 goes into 16 one
time 1 times 11 is 11. subtract we get a
5 and we bring down a 5. 11 goes into 55
exactly 5 times 5 times 11 is 55
subtract
we have no remainder but then we bring
down this 0 and we do it one more time
11 goes into 0
0 times remember the decimal place is
right over here 0 times 11 is 0 and then
we have no remainder so last year he was
150 centimeters and it's always good to
do a reality check make sure for example
if i divided wrong and i somehow got 15
or i got 1500 just to make sure that
that wouldn't make any sense 150
centimeters you add 10 percent of that
10 of 150 is 15 centimeters so you add
10 percent of that you indeed do get to
165 centimeters for the first day of
school this year